écoutez et de pas être envoyés quand
même à l'étranger parce que là aussi
c'est quand même j'allais dire
discriminatoire puisque celles qui ont
les moyennes peuvent effectivement aller
payer 1000 ou 2000 euros en espagne ou
au royaume-uni ou en hollande celles qui
n'ont pas les moyennes bain soit le
gardent leur grossesse soit est-ce qu'il
ya encore dix ans nous retourne t d ce
thème je ne s'est officiellement de nom
mais on peut se le demander c'est un
sujet en tout cas français ce sujet de
l'avortement c'est aussi un sujet
européen le gouvernement on le sent
emmanuel macron a envie de faire de ce
sujet sociétal un de ces marqueurs il
veut le pousser au niveau européen
écoutez le d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
devant le parlement européen
emmanuel macron qui a dit donc qu'il
voulait intégrer l'avortement à la
charte des droits fondamentaux
est ce que c'est une bonne chose pour
vous alain milon intégré l'avortement je
ne sais pas intégré dit vg oui le droit
que ça la même chose attention très
exactement ces mots le droit à
l'avortement doit naître alors le droit
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans des précisément chaque nation oui
c'était c'est une bonne chose
le droit à l'avortement en tant que tel
je ne pense pas que ce soit une bonne
chose à moins de d2 déterminer un des
délais suffisants iliad étaient les
suivants un peu plus super temps
supérieur pardon dans d'autres pays
c'est vrai on l'a dit d'ailleurs encore
ici on autre jour ce qui est un petit
peu
osé parce qu'il ya d'autres choses à
voir dans ce sujet mais oui mais les vg
oui le droit à l'ivg heger doit être
inscrit dans la charte des droits
fondamentaux c'est important de le
défendre aussi au niveau européen
emilienne comme errol oui bien sûr
puisque le droit à l'avortement moi je
vais leur envoyer le droit à
l'avortement est un droit des femmes à
disposer de leur corps et donc que ce
droit fondamental qui doit être respecté
et effectivement non seulement en france
mais partout en europe donc c'est bien
de pouvoir le le défendre au niveau
européen la droite et la gauche qui
salue l'une des initiatives du président
de la république
ni la droite ni la gauche n'ont été
opposés à l'idée j'ai je rappelle que
quand lee vg a été proposée par simone
veil une partie de la droite et une
partie de la gauche puisque c'est un
problème sociétal est pas un problème
politique pure à voter c'est simone veil
l'a proposé et qu'on va sécher jacques
chirac est venu au secours de simone
veil au moment où elle était en
difficulté donc non
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu lire la
déclaration de madame la rapporteure
papa de vous mesdames les rapporter à
signer à 3 tu n'es pas opposé à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
elle s'oppose à certaines assez fort
allongement de deux autres options vos
lecteurs au 16 mai paal ivg en tant que
tel bien joué en posant tout à l'heure
une occupez-vous fait que le débat n'a
pas lieu c'est quand même la droite
c'est quand même
donc c'est quand même la droite et qui
va alors on a eu débat certes en
commission mais vous avez refusé quand
même en posant cette coupe et le débat
au niveau de la séance et c'est quand
même dommage qu'on puisse pas échanger
de façon sereine
[Musique]
sur sur un sujet qui touche quand même
aux droits des femmes un droit
tout à l'heure c'est intéressant parce
que il ya un symbole qui marque un
certain 42 ans après simone et c'est le
fait que roberta mais de ceux-là a été
élue nouvelle présidente du parlement
européen
cet eurodéputé qui est maltese et qui
est connu pour ses convictions anti ivg
est ce que ça vous inquiète tous les
deux oui bien sûr moi ça me choque pas
plus que ça m'inquiète mais ça me choque
puisque effectivement elle a annoncé
partout
nous notoriété publique qu elle est
contre la voir l'avortement elle est
connue surtout pour ça mais surtout
essentiellement connu pour ça et donc
oui ça me choque que on est à la tête au
niveau de l'europe une femme qui
défendent des valeurs contraires à
celles comme même le prix d'un maquereau
a défendu le droit à l'avortement donc
je trouve ça très chaud quand vous vous
êtes choqué aussi alain milon et puisque
vous faisiez référence à simone veil
elle qui s'est battu pour le droit à
l'avortement qui a aussi présidé le
parlement européen lui justement
elle succède à simone veil saison quand
le ca le symbole est extrêmement
important maintenant elle est c'est moi
de le dire comme ça mais c'est peut-être
pas la bonne expression mais elle n'est
que présidente du parlement européen et
le président de la république française
propose l'introduction donc dans les
droits européens du droit à l'avortement
du droit dirigez je pense que chaque
pays va réagir à sa façon je ne pense
pas qu'elle ait le pouvoir de modifier
les lois de des pays de l'union
européenne en tout cas il faut l'espérer
parce que ce serait une régression et
azur effectivement à simone veil il faut
appeler quand même le combat
extraordinaire qui était ce une si bonne
nouvelle il vient effectivement les
compromis qu'elle a du
tram et en coulisses et les reliefs du
mans avec jacques chirac avec gaston
defferre de l'autre côté enfin bon
l'histoire est connue mais effectivement
c'est quelqu'un qui a vraiment une très
très grande importance et c'est un peu
dommage qu effectivement que celle qui
lui succède en tant que femme je veux
dire au niveau du parlement européen est
une position aussi contraire à celle que
défend dé simone veil et cela d'autant
que par exemple il ya eu une marche le
week-end dernier il ya eu des militants
opposés à l'avortement qui voudraient
faire de ce sujet une thématique de
campagne ils s'opposent et bien à ce cet
allongement du délai légal de l'ibg il
s'oppose hostiles à toute mesure comme
l'euthanasie ils n'étaient que quelques
milliers mais ce droit il a aussi été
remis en cause pas si loin de chez nous
à emilienne poumirol on a les défilés de
femmes en pologne en espagne en 2013 on
se rappelle que ce droit et bien il
avait été ils avaient été très très
fragilisée même plus que cela l'avait
été il y avait un projet d'interdiction
de livres et j'ai en espagne qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire cela est bien le
fait qu'ils aient c'est ce contexte en
europe
je crois que malheureusement au niveau
européen envoie j'allais dire excusez
moi d'employer ce terme me nommer une
certaine droitisation où certaines
contrées rva tisme il repli sur soi
dis-moi m'inquiète en repli
communautaire un repli religieux en
repli sur certaines valeurs qui diffuse
dans bon nombre de pays d'europe et
stroke site inquiétante parce que ça
fait resurgir j'allais dire de mauvais
souvenirs d'une époque où ces valeurs là
était
effectivement mise à mal donc moi
effectivement ça m'inquiète mon
inquiétude partagée alain milon on le
voit bien sur ce défilé de femmes par
exemple en pologne qui se battent pour
ce qu'elles seront pouvait penser comme
acquis ça ne l'est jamais
je pense que rien n'est jamais rien
n'est jamais acquis malheureusement des
mais nous vivons dans une démocratie
ce qu'il faut c'est préserver la
démocratie tout le temps est toujours
après certains peuvent exprimer ce
qu'ils expriment par rapport aux ivg
d'autres par rapport aux enfants
handicapés je pense qu'à un moment ou à
un autre il faut savoir être enfin
vision qu'on m'a d'eric zemmour et leur
dire ça suffit et si on peut le dire
nous en tant que politique ça suffit
après il faut qu évidemment derrière
dans le cadre des votes nos concitoyens
nous suivent dans le à ça suffit si une
majorité de français s'expriment pour
madame hidalgo pour madame pécresse pour
monsieur macron ça veut dire que les
autres ont tort à un moment ou un autre
c'est la majorité qui a raison ce tout
et la majorité qui a raison tout de
suite on va rejoindre alexandre poussard
on va parler bien de l'actualité
européenne actualité européenne c'est ce
grand oral d' emmanuel macron ce matin
devant les députés européens qu'en pense
martin décidera avec la sénatrice l est
républicain des yvelines qui est à votre
micro bonjour martha de séverac bonjour
comment vous avez ressenti ce grand oral
des manuels macron qui est 1 est à la
tête de la présidence française de
l'union européenne alors écoutez grand
oral je ne sais pas en fait en réalité
tout ce qu'il a dit il avait déjà dit
par le passé il n'y a rien de
fondamentalement je dirais nouveau dans
ce qu'il a pu exprimer ce matin devant
le parlement ce que je dirai simplement
c'est que les ambitions qui semble
vouloir afficher en réalité pour un
certain nombre d'entre elles sont déjà
inscrits dans des dans le parcours de
l'union bien évidemment et puis de nos
pays membres mais que l'ambition sur un
certain nombre de sujets est telle que
je ne sais pas du tout comment nous
allons pouvoir y arriver à 27 ah bah
tiens justement on parlait sur notre
plateau de livres et j'ai le président a
un public qui est favorable et bien à
l'introduction du droit les vg dans la
charte des droits fondamentaux européens
ce serait une bonne idée non ce n'est
pas une bonne idée pour une raison toute
simple c'est que aujourd'hui on voit
bien que pour beaucoup de sujets il est
indispensable d'avoir l'accord de
l'ensemble des états membres
là en l'occurrence nous sommes encore
dans sur un sujet très sensible pour
lequel on le sait bien nous avons
notamment deux pays la pologne et malté
sachant que nous avons eues présidente
maintenant du parlement qui est maltese
et qui s'oppose à liv et j'ai donc moi
je voudrais bien qu'on m'explique
comment notre président envisage pendant
ce laps de temps qui en plus s'est
quelque peu amputé de par nos élections
nationales
envisage d'arriver à convaincre autant
d'états membres pour se mettre d'accord
sur un sujet aussi sensible pour lequel
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas véritablement
de consensus c'est donc ça voudrait dire
qu'un et à la pologne et une présence du
parlement européen la maltaise anti
viger ça pourrait bloquer cette
reconnaissance du droit à l'avortement
je crois que c'est un travail que chaque
pays doit faire au simple de sa propre
deux sons de ses propres frontières en
france c'est un travail qui a été fait
depuis longtemps nous avons beaucoup
avancé sur ces thématiques là d'autres
pays je cite aussi l'irlande 1 tout
récemment qui a quand même fait un grand
pas dans ce sens là pour les femmes et
il me semble que c'est un petit peu
allez j'ose le dire un peu prétentieux
de la part de notre président dans le
contexte actuel d'annoncer cela comme ça
comme étant une grande ambition parce
qu'on sait bien que sur de longs fin
pendant cette présidence on n'y arrivera
pas sur l'environnement qui est un de
vos sujets de prédilection emmanuel
macron là aussi à renforcer la
protection de l'environnement dans les
textes européens ça par contre ce serait
une bonne idée ou oui c'est une bonne
idée bien sûr est d'ailleurs appelée
vaut à l'occasion de la loi climat nous
mène ici nous nous sommes prononcés tous
groupes confondus
en préambule mais là encore nous y
travaillons en ce moment même la
commission des affaires européennes nous
travaillons avec mon collègue d'ailleurs
j'arrive le compte sur ce qu'elle a
justement de l'objectif 55 dans le cadre
du green deal européen donc le sénat
c'est en fait
sur le même sujet donc là encore je
dirai où on s'inscrit notre présidence
française de l'union s'inscrit dans la
continuité des ambitions fortes comment
on va y arriver c'est un autre débat
puisque il faut mettre tout cela en
corrélation avec notre stratégie bas
carbone stratégie nationale bas carbone
il faut se dire que depuis 90 notamment
baissé que de 24% l'objectif donc 55
voyez il nous reste encore un grand pas
à franchir et le chemin est encore long
sur la protection de l'environnement
merci beaucoup pensent y merci alexandre
un mode europe un bon marketing qui
n'est pas du tout d'accord avec vous à
alain milon a trop belle que c'est
prétentieux de vouloir inscrire le droit
à l'image et au sein de la charte des
droits fondamentaux normaux comme sur
cette séquence emmanuel macron donc
président de l'union européenne alors
que début de cette campagne on sent au
style déjà presque candidat à la
présidentielle qui arrive à grands pas
au mois d'avril alain milon j'ai
l'impression que ça ne fait aucun doute
pour personne qui sera évidemment
candidat et que le fait de présider le
conseil de l'europe lui permet d'avoir
une tribune supplémentaire et en mettant
fin à cinq ans
dit le choix de faire effectivement
cette présidence de l'union européenne
au moment de la campagne au moment de la
campagne ça peut être embêtant pour les
candidats pour moi ça me gêne pas de
toute façon y arrivera pas à me
convaincre donc c'est pas le problème
mais
je veux dire je veux revenir sur sur ce
droit à l'avortement si on prend ce qui
existe sur le territoire national en
france le droit à l'avortement c'est une
interruption volontaire de grossesse
pour l'instant jusqu'à 12 semaines et
l'interruption médicale de grossesse
elle on a aussi le droit pour des
raisons médicales de faire une
interruption de grossesse ou pour sauver
langue pour sauver la mère généralement
donc si ce droit là est mis en place au
niveau de l'europe tant mieux tant mieux
pour les femmes tant mieux pour
l'ensemble 0 point qu'elle soit maltaise
ou polonaises allez un dernier mot là
dessus et mylène poumirol peut-être un
mot aussi de politiques sur ce président
de l'union européenne déjà quasi
candidat oui mais il est bien évident
pour tout le monde et depuis longtemps
que j'ai pas chrono sera candidat à
l'élection présidentielle et qu'il est
effectivement l'opportunité avec la
présidence au niveau de l'union
européenne de faire valoir ses idées
c'est évident ce qui me gêne un peu moi
c'est dans le décompte d'être du temps
de parole et co n'est pas une règle qui
soit suffisamment clair là dessus pour
qu'on puisse aussi quand même décompter
le temps de parole parce que sinon il a
une présence qui est quand même beaucoup
plus importante que celle de tous les
autres candidats bon alors mais après je
crois que personne n'a été dupe on sait
bien comme suit macron sera candidat le
10 avril évidence elle est déjà dans
tous les esprits merci est mienne
pomérols merci alain milon d'avoir
participé à ce face à face c'est
toujours sur ce sujet on va d'ailleurs
rejoindre alexandre qui se trouve avec
le sénateur socialiste rachid tu es mal
weir a chuté mal on parle de la
présidentielle avec cet abandon d'arnaud
montebourg qui a été candidat mais
finalement retire sa candidature c'est
plus sage compte tenu de des intentions
de vote un jeu d'abord c'est sa position
c'est sa décision je n'ai pas la
commenter mais comme l'évoqué anne
hidalgo il ya quelques jours encore à
l'issue de la présentation de son projet
ou fière de son équipe c'est il ya la
réalité du mois de janvier et puis au
mois de mars on verra qui sera sur la
ligne de départ et puis on fera ce
moment là un autre une autre en pagne
donc ce qui est clair c'est
qu'aujourd'hui à hidalgo est la seule
candidate de gauche abbas signature à
avoir un projet ambitieux et réaliste et
crédible aller sur le terrain et nous
allons les uns les autres la compagnie
pour aller chercher voix par vois pas ce
qu'il ya un électorat de gauche dans ce
pays ça après 40 45 % et ils ont besoin
lecteurs à gauche de gens qui vont
changer leur vie concrètement sire que
quentin propose la hausse des salaires
quand elle propose notamment qu' il est
plus de passion énergétique et donc on a
envie joue mieux dans nos logements tout
ça c'est des mesures concrètes et celle
d'al go qui peut les porter et puis je
rappelle puisque c'est la semaine aussi
l ago est la seule qui a des partenaires
européens pour changer l'europe l'efsc
l'europe notamment i les droits sociaux
contrairement à ce que dit le prélat
public et donc pour qui cela elle a des
partenaires allemand espagnol portugais
aux nordiques des premiers et donc à
l'anc a passé de le faire donc que c'est
pour ça que nous sommes totalement
concentrés sur notre échange de diallo
entre anne hidalgo et les françaises et
les français alors vous êtes concentré
mais finalement quand on regarde les
paires filmant des candidatures à gauche
finalement est-ce que anne hidalgo ne
devrait pas faire comme arnaud
montebourg et se retirer pour qu'il y
ait une seule candidature à gauche et
pourquoi accéder au second tour sauf que
vos dans votre raisonnement il ya un
petit détail si je vais remettre ces cas
hidalgo aujourd'hui je le redis est la
seule est en capacité
techniquement politiquement par son
projet par sa signature par le premier
réseau d'élus en france à gauche ce sont
les socialistes qui donc les français
ont voté pour eux ses partenaires
européens c'est une femme d'état qu'avec
déjà les élections d'amour à paris et
donc si elle doit ou quelqu'un doit
rester c'est anne hidalgo donc anne
hidalgo je leur dis vous aurez
le 10 avril prochain dans tous les
bureaux de votre de france et de navarre
le bulletin à d'hidalgo le bulletin de
la gauche pour changer la vie
quotidienne des français notamment si je
prends l'exemple l'augmentation du smic
200 euros plus cet ado qui le portent un
voile sur la primaire de la gauche anne
hidalgo étaient d'abord favorable à l
effet un appel à la primaire christiane
taubira les aussi finalement signé
dargaud a changé d'avis c'est quoi c'est
un rétro pédalage et finalement est ce
que cette primaire se serait pas la
solution unique pour avoir et bien une
gauche rassemblée d'abord vous dans
votre commentaire un delgo est la seule
candidate de gauche alors fait une
proposition sérieuse crédible et public
de discussion de rassemblement il
s'avère que l avais dit voilà les
conditions pour y arriver un dialogue
entre les candidats pour organiser une
primaire les partenaires potentiels je
pense au vert d'autres candidats n'ont
pas souhaité participer et donc il n'ya
pas de primaire aujourd'hui ce que vous
évoquez vous c'est une consultation en
ligne d'une association une forme d'un
tri mais enfin une forme de sondage
c'est une constatation est chronique il
y aura je pas cette constation là je
crois qu'il ya des débats actuellement
sur les modalités et les objectifs réels
et après une vidéo d'un des porte parole
et donc cela ne concerne pas une dalle
guénaël go encore une fois et dont le
rapport à une présence est celle qui
paraît de penser et qui vont être les
français et ce que christiane taubira
n'a pas raison en appelant à une
primaire de l'agression taubira c'est
celle qui avait dit qu'elle ne serait
pas candidate supplémentaire pour qu'il
forme un tout bien comment elle peut
changer d'avis merci beaucoup a insisté
mal et on va tout de suite allé dans la
tribune de presse de l'hémicycle du
sénat retrouver audrey vue états audrey
calé programme cet après-midi alors
alexandre la première question sur 17
sera sur la présidence française du
conseil de l'union européenne elle sera
pourrait se poser par pierre laurent du
groupe communiste vous le savez emmanuel
macron vient de terminer un grand oral
devant le parlement européen il a
égrainé les grandes ambitions pour la
présidence française de ce conseil de
l'union européenne parmi elles la
réforme de l'espace schengen une europe
sociale la protection de l'environnement
et l'inscription de l'île et j'ai dans
les droits fondamentaux européens il a
aussi eu beaucoup de questions des
eurodéputés français sur la
présidentielle française alors ça
devrait être un thème important de ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
aujourd'hui aussi edf devrait aussi être
au coeur des débats trois questions sont
prévues à ce sujet et on a vu bruno le
maire s'installer dans l'hémicycle il a
déjà donné des gages un aux salariés
d'edf qui s'inquiètent des mesures
prises par le gouvernement pour protéger
le pouvoir d'achat des français et
limiter l'augmentation du prix des
énergies mais vous l'avez entendu la
cloche a sonné je vous laisse suivre les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
[Musique]
il y en a t'il en séance
je l'envoie points il est donc adoptée
sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues par lettre en date de ce
jour la commission des affaires sociales
demande au sénat en application de
l'article 5 ter de l' ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires que lui
conférait les prérogatives attribuées
aux commission denquête pour une durée
de six mois afin de mener sa mission
d'information sur l'adéquation du pas
actional d évolution de l'épidémie de
covile 19
la conférence des présidents examinera
cette demande lors de sa réunion de ce
jour à 16h30
notant les jours appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
notre silence et retransmis sur public
sénat et notre site internet chacun sera
attentif au respect des uns et des
autres et au respect du temps de parole
redonner la parole au président pierre
laurent pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes
monsieur le président vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre le président de la
république a lancé aujourd'hui devant le
parlement repère la présidence française
de l'union européenne
les défis à relever sont nombreux
mais l'échec social est au coeur des
crises qui déchire l'union l'union a été
longtemps réduite un vaste champ de mise
en concurrence ou le progrès social est
sacrifiée aujourd'hui face aux pandémies
au dérèglement climatique au nez aux
inégalités tout esprit lucide admet que
l'europe doit changer de trajectoire le
temps est venu de passer du logiciel
tout pour le marché la concurrence et la
finance à un nouveau logiciel tout pour
la solidarité l'humain et la planète on
va entendre beaucoup de belles paroles
on en a entendu encore ce matin on parle
européen mais ce sont les actes qui vont
compter sur la santé la levée des
brevets l'axé international au vaccin
sera-t-il une priorité de la présidence
française
la france proposera un tel la sortie des
dépenses publiques et de recherche pour
la santé des critères soumis à
autorisation du semestre européen
sur les salaires la france proposera
elle enfin dans la directive sur les
salaires minimum actuellement en
négociation une norme minimale
contraignantes ou restera-t-elle dans le
camp de ceux qui combattent août normes
contraignantes dans cette directive sur
les travailleurs de plateformes la
france agira tel pour consacrer le
principe de la présomption de relations
de travail ouvrant la voie au
rétablissement des droits sociaux pour
ces travailleurs contre les relations
actuelles de surexploitation et enfin
sur les carcans d'austérité budgétaire
qui ont dû être suspendues tellement il
aurait été mortifère en temps de
pandémie leurs révisions fera t-elle
l'objet d'un débat national au parlement
dans les collectivités locales et dans
le pays avant leur révision
pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre de l'économie
des finances et de la relance monsieur
bruno le maire
le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
[Applaudissements]
je vais venir plus souvent
monsieur le sénateur laurent
si vous vous permettez je crois que
c'est d'abord le parti communiste qui
devrait changer de logiciel
parce que la réalité c'est que l'europe
elle a déjà changé au cours de cette
crise quel est le continent qui a le
mieux protéger ses salariés avec
l'activité partielle pendant la crise
économique c'est continent européen quel
est le continent qui a le mieux protéger
ses entreprises et éviter des centaines
de milliers de faillite pendant la crise
la plus grave que nous ayons et
connaître depuis 1929 c'est le continent
européen quel est le continent qui sous
l'impulsion des mails macron et d'angela
merkel a décidé de lever de la dette en
commun pour la première fois de son
histoire pour financer des mesures de
protection et de relance économique face
à la crise c'est le continent européen
quel est le seul continent au monde qui
est en train de réfléchir installèrent
minimum commun c'est le continent
européen quel est le seul continent au
monde qui est en train de se doter de
mesures de protection environnementale
en réfléchissant sous présidence
française un mécanisme d'ajustement
carbone aux frontières pour protéger nos
intérêts environnementaux tout en
protégeant nos industries c'est le
continent européen quel est le continent
qui a porté le plus de soutien aux pays
en développement en leur apportant des
vaccins c'est le continent européen quel
est le seul continent qui a insisté sur
le risque de grandes divergences entre
les pays les moins développés et les
pays les plus développés après la crise
en demandant qu'on apporte 100 milliards
de dollars de soutien financier aux pays
africains les plus pauvres c'est le
continent européen alors regardez
l'europe telle qu'elle est monsieur le
sénateur considéré à quel point elle a
changé et à perte nous votre soutien
dans la construction de cette europe
solidaire efficace que nous sommes en
train de construire et que présente la
république
la parole est au président françois
patriat pour le gros du rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et à
dépendant de la parole merci
[Applaudissements]
merci merci cher collègue monsieur le
président sur les mesdames messieurs les
ministres monsieur le premier ministre
la violence de la crise salutaire que
nous connaissons ne doit en aucun cas
nous écarter de l'impératif économique
et celui de la réindustrialisation de
notre pays la france
entre 2019 2017 et 2021 a maintenu et
créer 140 mille emplois autour d' autour
de autour de plusieurs projets qui sont
de l'attractivité de la france d'un
élément indispensable aujourd'hui et si
business france reconnaît que la france
est devenue le premier pays en europe en
termes d'attractivité pour les emplois
il devenu même devant le royaume-uni
situation que nous pouvions pas imaginer
il ya encore quelques années et puis
revenu lundi le jour là dans de tous
france et tous france a décidé qu'il y
aurait en france une vingtaine de
projets avec 4 milliards
d'investissements pour les années à
venir et même à partir de cette année
ses investissements se traduiront en
france par la création de dix mille cdi
et de 15000 cdi intérimaires qui seront
répartis sur le territoire français
entre les villes grandes villes mais la
moitié pour les villes de moins de vingt
mille habitants c'est quichard collègues
et amis sénateurs devraient réduire la
plupart d'entre nous qui vous battez
pour des territoires plutôt ruraux qui
sont en difficulté mais ces résultats
mais chers collègues ne sont pas dus au
hasard ils sont dus d'une part au
savoir-faire à la connaissance à la
technicité des entreprises françaises
qui se sont adaptés et qu'ils restent
dans bien des domaines et domaine de
luxe je pense à la pharmacie je pense à
l'environnement je pense à la
mécatronique des sujets qui sont
aujourd'hui très important et ça n'est
pas le fruit du hasard ce n'est pas le
fruit du hasard c'est aussi au regard
des mesures qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement concernant concernant notre
activité contre non le savoir faire
concernant les impôts de production
concernant la simplification pour les
entreprises il y à aujourd'hui en france
il ya aujourd'hui en france
14% d'emploi venant d'étrangers qui sont
aidés alors ma question monsieur
polémique hier tout noir ou tout blanc
ni la question comment le gouvernement
entend t-il prendre des mesures pour
conforter ses acquis et rendra la france
+ ap activité encore je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
pour une mini
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président françois patriat vous avez
tout à fait raison
l'attractivité mais
je sais que vous manifestez passe
qualité de ces résultats vous vous
réjouissez
l'attractivité l'attractivité d'un pays
est en effet l'un des indices de sa
santé économique vous avez donné des
indications très précises sur ce que
souffrance a porté cette année à notre
pays je voudrais élargir le propos
monsieur le sénateur depuis
2010cette entre 2017 et 2020 donc
s'ajouteront les éléments que vous
n'êtes communiqué plus de 5300 projets
ont permis de créer ou de maintenir
140 mille emplois en france grâce aux
investissements internationaux sur notre
pays c'est une excellente chose je pense
que personne ne le contestera et vous
l'avez dit évidemment je ne peux que
vous relayez ça concerne mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs tous nos
territoires
j'ai une cartographie que je tiens à
votre disposition la france entière est
énervé par ces projets et si vous
permettez
d'insister ces projets concours à la
réindustrialisation de notre pays à
laquelle je vous sais aussi très attaché
là aussi là aussi ça oui un peu tard
vous des pieux là aussi oui oui les
chiffres vous savez que depuis
1981 mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
la france a perdu 50 mille emplois
industriels par an 58 depuis 2010 est en
net nous en avons recréé 30000 certes on
n'est pas encore à la hauteur de ce
qu'on a détruit mais mais le mouvement
est amorcé et je dois vous préciser
d'ailleurs que en 2021 nous avons ouvert
deux fois plus d' usine qu'il n'ya eu de
fermeture et ça aussi c'est totalement
inédit je pourrais évidemment vous dire
illustration de la politique
gouvernementale et de ses conséquences
je pourrais également vous dira tout à
tous que ces chiffres sont en ligne avec
ceux de la croissance économique de
noter la plus forte de la zone euro que
ces chiffres sont en ligne avec les
créations d'emplois plus
575000 créations nettes d'emplois aux
trois premiers trimestres de 2010 21 ça
fait des années et des années que ça
n'était pas arrivé que même ces chiffres
sont en ligne je vous le dis avec le
pouvoir d'achat qui a augmenté parce que
créer des emplois c'est la première
mesure en faveur du pouvoir d'achat plus
2,2 pour cent en 2021 alors qu'il a
reculé en allemagne tout ça ce sont des
données concrètes alors qu'allons nous
faire monsieur le président pour
poursuivre en ce sens et conforter ses
résultats économiques et bien tout
simplement continuer la politique
économique et sociale que nous
conduisons au service de la france et
les français
merci la parole
est à notre collègue thierry cozic pour
le groupe socialiste
écologiste et république
merci monsieur merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
l'économie mes chers collègues alors que
les prix d'énergie font l'objet d'une
hausse très conséquente vous avez choisi
en pleine campagne présidentielle
et au nom de la défense du pouvoir
d'achat de faire
disons le franchement les poches d'edf
tout le monde l'aura compris la seule
réponse que vous êtes en mesure
d'apporter face à la flambée du prix de
l'énergie relève au mieux de
l'improvisation au pire du cynisme
électoral vous fait peser sur edf
l'entière soutenabilité financière des
mesures gouvernementales de campagne
après avoir tardivement compris que
votre chèque énergie 200 euros n'avait
que peu d'effets face à la montée des
prix vous êtes aventuré sur d'autres
mesures votre décision pourrait coûter 8
milliards d'euros à edf alors que
l'urgence serait de financer le
renouvellement et l'entretien du parc
productif
force est de constater que le marché
d'énergie en france est devenue le
royaume de la financiarisation le parc
de production électrique n'a jamais
réellement été agrandi et le
développement des énergies renouvelables
stack de toujours sur les quarante
fournisseurs
plus de 35 sont des fournisseurs
virtuels qui ne produisent pas un
kilowatt mais ce pécule à partir d
approvisionnement garanti par edf le
tout en empochant la différence
que l'on retrouve pour ces sociétés
domiciliées dans des paradis fiscaux
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
mettre en place les mesures nécessaires
afin d'arrêter de subventionner une
concurrence factice au mépris de
l'intérêt général et qui ne contribue
qu'à l'enrichissement privé pour vous
reprendre la parole et collègue de
l'économie des dinos larmes aux yeux le
maire
et monsieur le sénateur quand est ce que
nous allons prendre avec le premier
ministre avec présent la république les
mesures nécessaires
c'est simple maintenant gouverner c'est
choisir et nous notre choix il a été
fait c'est protéger les français contre
l'augmentation massive des prix de
l'électricité et protéger nos
entreprises contre une augmentation
insupportable de leurs coûts de
production contrairement à ce que vous
dites que sur le sénateur les premiers à
avoir payé c'est par edf c'est l'état
qui a renoncé à 8 milliards d'euros de
la taxe intérieure sa combine sommation
finale d'électricité pour aider les
consommateurs et leur permettre de
supporter l'augmentation des prix
d'électricité ensuite nous avons demandé
à l'edf effectivement d'être mises à
contribution je rappelle que edf quand
les prix sont très bas et quand les
revenus ne sont pas suffisants peut
compter sur le soutien de l'état et à
compter sur le soutien de l'inter qui
depuis 2015 lui apporter 10 milliards
d'euros dès de la capitalisation de
renoncement dividendes pour l'aider à se
financer il me paraît juste il me paraît
normal qu'une entreprise publique comme
edf participe au soutien des français
des ménages et des entreprises quand les
prix les tricité flambent c'est bien ma
conception des services publics et c'est
bien la conception d'une grande
entreprise publique comme edf nous avons
donc décidé d'augmenter le volume des
tarifs de l'électricité vendue à prix
réduit la répercussion sera intégrale et
les fournisseurs ne s'en remettront pas
plein les poches que nous avons demandé
à la commission de régulation de
l'électricité d'ici le mois de juin peut
faire la transparence totale sur la
répercussion intégrale de la baisse des
prix de l'électricité sur le
consommateur final c'est à dire sur les
entreprises en particulier les grandes
entreprises industrielles qui avaient
besoin de ce soutien
ce qui vous surprend en fait que ce
sénateur c'est que pour une fois vous
avait des responsables politiques qui
tiennent leurs promesses le premier
ministre avait promis que les prix de
l'électricité ne montrait pas de plus de
4% pour les consommateurs français ce
sera le cas promesse tenue ça nous
change de la politique du passé
monsieur le ministre votre réponse ne me
font me convainquent pas je vous parle
de problèmes systémiques et structurant
pour edf vous m'apportez une réponse
conjoncturelle le marché l'énergie est
devenu en france un gigantesque far-west
financier qui ne sert que ses intérêts
où est l'intérêt public dans tout ça
cette spéculation est une lame de fond
qui grève le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens et place le df dans une
situation intenable pour les années à
venir avec cette opération vous
détruisez notre fleuron industriel
comme le veut l'adage lorsque l'on veut
tuer son chien on dit qu'il a la rage
avec cette mesure monsieur le ministre
vous venez dans rage et edf et c'est
bien regrettable
merci
la parole est à notre collègue et
rigolent
et rigole pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
alors que le taux de chômage stagne
autour de 8% la reprise économique a
fait apparaître un phénomène croissant
qui marque une adéquation entre les
emplois disponibles et les candidats à
l'emploi au troisième trimestre 2021 on
comptait 280 6000 postes vacants 33% de
plus qu'avant la crise sanitaire cette
situation touche plus particulièrement
les secteurs de l'hôtellerie
restauration du btp de l'industrie du
commerce de la santé et du grand âge des
transports et de la logistique
les difficultés sont particulièrement
visibles dans la restauration elles le
sont également dans les hôpitaux où le
manque de personnel aggrave encore des
conditions de travail déjà très délicate
cela concerne à la fois des emplois très
qualifiés pour lesquelles nous manquons
de candidats et des emplois peu
qualifiés ou le vivier de manoeuvre
existent mais où l'attractivité des
métiers fait défaut
ces deux situations nécessitent des
mesures différencier mieux adapter
l'offre de formation au marché du
travail et améliorer les conditions
d'emploi le gouvernement a d'ailleurs
lancé un plan à l'automne fondée sur ces
deux principes pour réduire les tensions
de recrutement
mais d'après l'avis publié
par le conseil économique social et
environnemental
les politiques en la matière doit
toucher inspectent au bien plus large au
delà des mesures d'activité des métiers
tels que les hausses de salaires le
céser pointe des freins périphériques à
l'emploi et donc l'importance d'une
politique globale touchant au logement
social aux solutions d'accueil des
jeunes enfants ou accor ou encore la
couverture du territoire en moyens de
transport collectif
aussi madame la ministre
allez vous adaptez votre plan de lutte
contre les difficultés de recrutement et
associer les collectivités locales dans
une politique à la fois plus globale et
plus adaptée à chaque territoire je vous
remercie
on nous répond de la parole car madame
la visite du travail de l'emploi et de
la chaire sur madame board merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur eric gold les tensions de
recrutement persistante peuvent être
source de difficultés pour les
entreprises mais elles sont aussi une
bonne nouvelle elles sont le signe que
la reprise est robuste il nous faut donc
accompagner cette reprise en répondant
aux besoins de main d'oeuvre des
entreprises qui constituent autant
d'opportunités pour les jeunes et les
demandeurs d'emplois depuis le début du
quinquennat nous investissons comme
jamais auparavant dans la formation avec
le plan d'investissement dans les
compétences à hauteur de 15 milliards
d'euros et plus récemment 1,4 milliard
d'euros sont venus compléter ses efforts
en visant particulièrement des
formations en entreprise ou en
alternance qui prépare directement à un
emploi mais comme vous l'avez souligné
il s'agit également de renforcer
l'attractivité des métiers en tension
c'est le sens des discussions que j'ai
engagée avec certaines branches pour les
inciter à revaloriser leurs minima
conventionnels et à améliorer leurs
conditions de travail
branche des hôtels cafés restaurants a
ainsi réussi à proposer une hausse
moyenne de plus de 16% et comme le
souligne le cee dans son avis il nous
faut également lever l'ensemble des
freins périphériques au retour à
l'emploi c'est avant tout à l'échelle
locale que des réponses peuvent être
construite en partenariat avec les
collectivités
nous avons donc demandé à chaque sous
préfet d'identifier avec les acteurs
locaux les solutions qui peuvent être
proposées aux demandeurs d'emploi en
tenant compte des spécificités des
territoires
enfin il nous faut nous assurer que les
demandeurs d'emploi qui ces formations
sont proposées s'en saisisse
effectivement et réponde aux offres
d'emploi et c'est aussi le sens du
contrôle de la recherche d'emploi qui a
conduit à une radiation de près de 18 %
des demandeurs d'emploi contrôler au
cours du mois de décembre donc monsieur
le sénateur l'ensemble de ces actions
commencent à porter leurs fruits ces
derniers mois les embauches ont atteint
un niveau inégalé depuis près de 20 ans
merci monsieur vol
oui merci madame larina ministre pour
votre réponse beaucoup de secteurs sont
aujourd'hui en souffrance nous comptons
réellement sur vous pour mettre en
oeuvre tous les leviers pour le retour
rapide à l'emploi des plus grand nombre
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue monique de marco pour le groupe
écologie solidarité territoire il y
avait la parole
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues on ne pourra pas
rester durablement dans un système où
l'enseignement supérieur n'a aucun prix
pour la quasi totalité des étudiants
voici les mots du président de la
république qui ont tout choqué les
étudiants et le personnel d'une
université
si le but est de faire baisser la
précarité étudiante en rendant moins
accessible universités aux plus
précaires c'est inacceptable
cette vision de l'université s'inscrit
dans la continuité d'un mandat plus que
décevante la dépense par étudiant a
continué à baisser le bilan du parcours
stups est plus que mitigé
l'université est un sous financement
chronique et les conditions
d'encadrement des étudiants ne cesse de
se dégrader
votre promesse de construction de 70000
logements étudiants est loin d'être tenu
la réforme promise des bourses n'a
jamais vu le jour remise à plus tard car
jugée trop complexe
sans oublier la gestion de la crise
sanitaire qui a été une totale
improvisation
de trop nombreux étudiants qui avait un
équilibre financier si fragiles ont
basculé dans une grande précarité
comment pouvez-vous encore ignorer le
nom d' inadmissibles d'étudiants ayant
recours à l'aide alimentaire
pour nous l'éducation et aucune société
de l'intelligence de la solidarité de
l'épanouissement et de l'émancipation
tout comme l'hôpital elle doit rester
gratuite
madame la ministre pouvez vous nous
éclairer sur ses orientations et ce
bilan qui n'augure rien de bon pour les
étudiantes et des étudiants je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est
calviniste l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche l'innovation alain vidal
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice di marco je connais
votre honnêteté intellectuelle et je
sais que vous avez à coeur de lire
l'entièreté des propos du président de
la république il a dit que
structurellement on ne pouvait pas
continuer à rester avec une université
qui n'avait quasiment aucun coût pour
les étudiants dans un monde où un tiers
des étudiants sont boursiers pourtant où
il ya énormément de précarité le tout
financé essentiellement par les deniers
publics et comme je suis sûr que vous
avez lu la suite des propos du président
vous avez vu les solutions qui ont été
proposées en aucun cas il n'a été
formulée l'augmentation des droits
d'inscription ça n'a été ni écrits ni
dit ni penser par contre ce que propose
le président de la république c'est
effectivement de prendre en compte la
précarité des étudiants
c'est effectivement de mettre le
bien-être et la vie étudiante au coeur
des préoccupations des politiques
publiques comme nous l'avons fait depuis
2017 et g2 demandé aux universités de
mieux travailler l'insertion
professionnelle à la formation continue
à la formation tout au long de la vie et
de le faire évidemment avec les futurs
employeurs de nos étudiants c'est ça le
projet que nous portons depuis cinq ans
alors madame la sénatrice moi j'aurais
aimé vous voir aux côtés du gouvernement
pour rajouter un milliard d'euros dans
le premier cycle de l'enseignement
supérieur ce que nous avons fait pour
voter 25 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour la recherche
française j'aurais aimé vous voir et
vous entends vous dit très souvent
madame la sénatrice que vous vous
préoccuper du bien-être des étudiants
puisque vous voulez c'est qu' il puisse
s'épanouir qui le soufre de risques
psychosociaux bien ce que vous faites en
affirmant que le président la république
veut augmenter les droits d'inscription
ce qu'il n'a jamais dit et ce qui ne se
fera pas et bien simplement vous
continuer à renforcer le sentiment de
détresse des étudiants aujourd'hui
le lob de marco
bon mais merci madame la ministre je
pense que nous n'avons pas la même
lecture des propos du président de la
république
pour ma part je vois bien que vous êtes
comme d'habitude satisfaite de votre
bilan mais les étudiants eux ne voient
aucun avenir à l'expo position comme
nous voulons une réforme des bourses des
investissements massifs dans
l'université et la mise en place d'une
allocation d'autonomie donc vos propos
ne sont pas une réponse donc à la tente
globalement des étudiants et des
universités je vous remercie merci sa
parole est à notre collègue france
venant ville pour le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le 13
janvier dernier le gouvernement
demandait à edf d'augmenter de 20% le
volume d'électricité issue de la filière
nucléaire vendu à prix réduits à ses
concurrents dans le cadre de la reine
cela afin de contenir à 4 % la hausse
des tarifs cette décision dont le coût
est estimé à ce jour à 8 milliards
d'euros traduit le seul de sombres
perspectives pour notre fleuron national
déjà lourdement fragiliser une dette de
44 milliards d'euros une chute de sa
cotation en bourse une révision à la
baisse des perspectives de production
nucléaire pour 2022 en arrêt ont raison
de l'arrêt d'un certain nombre de
réacteurs dans le cadre de leur
maintenance notamment à un retard et un
surcoût supplémentaire du projet de père
de flamanville des investissements
colossaux à entrevoir pour le parc
nucléaire existant mais bien évidemment
également l'apprend prévision de son
renouvellement je rappellerai aussi le
retrait du projet hercules mais si ces
annonces pour sauvegarder le pouvoir
d'achat des français sont louables elle
suscite beaucoup d'interrogations et de
et d'inquiétude et notamment dans notre
hémicycle elles vont aussi largement
profité à des concurrents sans certitude
que cela se répercute sur leurs clients
monsieur le ministre edf doit faire face
à beaucoup trop d'injonction
contradictoires fermeture de fessenheim
renouvellement du parc nucléaire grand
carénage et au sort d'un jean-louis sa
mise à contribution pour contrecarrer
les hausses du coût de l'énergie
tout ceci donc elles sont autant
d'éléments pour une équation insoluble
qui met en danger cette entreprise et
compromet lourdement son avenir à
l'heure où tout le monde parle de
souveraineté énergétique et où la france
prend la présidence du conseil de
l'union européenne
quelles perspectives comptez-vous tracé
pour edf qui concourt depuis 1946 à la
stratégie énergétique de la france
confort comptez-vous donc donné à élèves
les marges de sape de ses ambitions
vous répondre la parole est aux visites
de l'économie des finances et de la
relance vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le sénateur je rejoins
totalement
edf est une grande entreprise nationale
qui fait la fierté de tous les français
edf a toujours répondu présent lorsqu'il
y avait des difficultés
d'approvisionnement lorsqu'il y avait
des tempêtes lorsqu'il y avait des
accidents climatiques et je vous rendre
un hommage appuyé aux 130 mille salariés
d'edf en france au plus de 160000 à
travers le monde qui construit cette
fierté nationale je lui ai dit en
réponse à une autre question l'état a
toujours été aux côtés d'edf et lorsque
edf avait besoin de recapitalisation que
nous renoncions à nos dividendes l'état
a toujours répondu présent et l'état
répondra toujours présent pour edf et
pour les salariés d'edf nous demandons
un effort aujourd'hui oui comme l'état a
fait le sien pour une seule et unique
raison protéger les français protéger
les entreprises françaises contre une
augmentation des prix qui aurait été
insupportable imaginez les millions de
contribuables modestes de foyers
modestes qui ouvrent leur courrier le
1er février qui et couvre une facture
d'électricité qui a augmenté de 35 ou de
40 % serait insupportable pour les
ménages est insupportable pour les
entreprises maintenant nous voulons
ouvrir des perspectives de long terme la
première a été rappelé par le président
de la république nous voulons qu edf
soit un des leaders mondiaux la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires et le président de la
république le premier ministre toute
cette majorité ont fait un choix clair
en faveur de la réalisation de nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires c'est une vraie
perspective de développement pour edf la
deuxième réponse que nous voulons
l'emporter elle concerne le marché
européen d'énergie je l' ai déjà dit et
je le répète et je persiste et je signe
le fonctionnement du marché européen de
l'énergie est aberrant et je ne vois pas
pourquoi la france aurait à payer le
coût de son électricité au coût marginal
d'ouverture des centrales à gaz dans les
pays d'europe de l'est nous voulons
payer le coût moyen de production de
l'électricité en france nous voulons en
avoir pour notre argent pour nos
investissements dans le nucléaire et
nous voulons décorrélée une bonne fois
pour toutes le coût de l'électricité
produit en france du coup d'ouverture
marginale des centrales à gaz dans le
reste de l'europe
la parole est à madame la présidente
sophie primas pour le groupe des
républicains
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre la transition
énergétique ne se fera pas sans edf
enfin nous l'espérons puisque après ce
que nous venons d'entendre nous
commençons à douter il ne se passe pas
un mois sans que votre gouvernement ne
prenne des décisions qui fragilise edf
le relèvement du plafond de la reine on
vient d'en parlé plusieurs fois avec un
chiffre d'affaires de 8 milliards
d'euros qui manquera la fin de l'année
son patron d'ailleurs son pdg dit c'est
un véritable choc les son pdg mais aussi
les organisations syndicales le rachat
de l'ancienne filiale d'alstom arabelle
que vous aviez vendu à general electric
dont le rachat bien trop cher par edf
s'est imposée par le président de la
république
l'inconstance de votre stratégie
nucléaire dans le mandat précédent le
conseiller macron poussé à la fermeture
des réacteurs qui l'a confirmé comme
président avec fessenheim et voici trois
mois ils annoncent miraculeusement la
construction des ep m pourtant ce
n'était pas la pentecôte mais plus tard
mais plus encore c'est sur l'intégrité
même d'edf qu'il y a plus d'inconnues
puisque nous ne savons toujours pas ce
que vous allez faire de notre opérateur
national et je ne parle pas des
incertitudes sur les barrages alors ma
question est simple monsieur le premier
ministre au delà des belles paroles que
nous venons d'entendre avez vous décidé
de sacrifier edf
quand vous répondent la parole est aux
mini-jeux l'économie des finances et de
la roulante monsieur le maire
madame la présidente prima
je pense que comme vous hier soir j'ai
regardé l'émission de télévision ou
votre candidate à l'élection
présidentielle lmp presse
en réponse à une question sur qu'est-ce
qu'elle ferait face à l'augmentation de
40% détail de l'électricité pour les
ménages et pour les entreprises a
répondu je cite à court terme je n'ai
pas la solution la différence entre vous
et nous c'est que nous nous avons la
solution et que nous nous agissons
par ailleurs
quant à la solution que nous avons
adoptée qui est le relèvement du plafond
de l'arenh c'est-à-dire le relèvement du
plafond de volumes d'électricité
nucléaire produits à tarifs réduits que
nous avons augmenté de 20% de 100
térawattheures à 120 térawattheures
après avoir obtenu l'accord de la
commission européenne
je voudrais vous citez un courrier du
mentor de madame pécresse monsieur
fillon qui le 15 septembre 2009
s'adressait à la commission européenne
et indiquées
et indiqué madame rima
[Applaudissements]
et indiqué madame prima
[Musique]
mais basilan je suis
monsieur le président
et c'est quoi qui préside monsieur le
maire vous répondez à un prix bas voilà
je voudrais juste ce président entrant
situation répondre
je vous disais
je vous disais madame prima que monsieur
fillon a écrit en 2009 à la commission
européenne
que la seule solution était d'augmenter
le plafond de la reine afin que dans une
telle configuration le dispositif de
prix et des fonctionne de manière
efficace la solution que recommandait
monsieur fillon en 2009 à la commission
européenne pour protéger les français
contre l'augmentation des prix nous
n'avons décidé aujourd'hui pour protéger
des français contre une augmentation de
40% des prix de l'électricité nous
agissons pour protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des français
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente
sur avis que vous puissiez monsieur
fillon puisque c'est vrai que nous
faisions équipe à l'époque et vous étiez
le premier défenseur de sa politique
vous nous quittez
vous nous idée des décisions de court
terme et c'est ça qu'on vous reproche
c'est pas une politique énergétique de
long terme avec une vision à long terme
et depuis la médiatique loi
énergie-climat où les chantiers sont à
l'arrêt la réorganisation de ds la
réforme de la reine la construction des
réacteurs résultat nous ouvrons dans le
pays qui a signé les accords de paix y
rit des centrales à charbon
c'est une honte c'est un échec alors oui
monsieur le premier ministre et les
membres du gouvernement nous vous
accusons de sacrifier edf à une
manoeuvre politicienne pré-électorale et
vous en serez comptable devant les
français
[Applaudissements]
la parole est plat notre collègue
olivier cigolotti pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères monsieur le ministre
cela apparaît désormais comme une
certitude les mercenaires de la société
privée russe wagner sont largement
déployées au mali pour preuve il ya
quelques jours dans le centre du pays au
sud de mopti un accrochage opposant
éléments djihadistes et membre du groupe
wagner a fait plusieurs victimes les
autorités maliennes n'en sont plus à une
provocation près en continuant à nier la
présence des mercenaires russes d'un
pays et allant même jusqu'à remettre en
cause de survol de leur territoire par
les appareils de transport logistique
intervenant au profit de l'opération
barkan et ce malgré un accord de
coopération datant de 2013
lors du sommet d'accra ya une dizaine de
jours la cedeao a décidé de sanctions
très dures à l'encontre du régime du
colonel goïta qui propose en repent de
quatre ans des élections démocratiques
à la fin de l'année dernière paris
laissé entendre que le report des
élections malienne prévue le mois
prochain mais surtout l'arrivée du
groupe wagner serait inacceptable force
est de constater que nous avons été mis
devant le fait accompli
avec le redimensionnement de la force
barkan se posera également la question
de la mission des nations unies pour la
stabilisation du mali et le déploiement
de la force takouba monsieur le ministre
neuf ans après le début de l'opération
militaire au sahel le mali remettent en
cause la présence française sur son sol
plus le temps passe et plus les états
contributeurs européens en particulier
vont se poser des questions pouvons-nous
durablement envisager une présence sur
un territoire où nous ne sommes plus les
bienvenus dans ces conditions mais suite
à la réunion à brest des ministres des
affaires étrangères des vingt-sept
quelle position la france et bruxelles
entend qu'il adopte et on vous répond la
parole est au
ministère du commerce extérieur
merci monsieur le président mais les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur cigolotti comme
vous l'avez dit la présence la présence
avérée de wagner au mali est un symptôme
de la fuite en avant dans laquelle la
junte d'être engagé comme la cedeao l'a
révélé et l'a relevé la junte et c'est
de prendre en otage le peuple malien
pour les champs cinq prochaines années
et c'est absolument inacceptable
wagner ne vient pas pour lutter contre
le terrorisme il ne l'a jamais fait
d'ailleurs en afrique mais pour assurer
le maintien au pouvoir de la junte dans
ce contexte les chefs d'état de la
cedeao ont pris à l'unanimité les
décisions fortes et courageuses
fermeture des frontières et de l'espace
aérien malien arrêt des transactions
commerciales et financières gel de
l'assistance financière de l'uemoa il
revient maintenant à la junte de prendre
des actes vont se conformer aux
engagements pris au risque de s'enfermer
dans un isolement régional et
international alors l'union européenne
appuie très résolument et de manière
unanime ce les décisions fortes de nos
partenaires africains
quel sens des discussions d'ailleurs que
le ministre le drian a eu avec ses
homologues européens lors de la réunion
du gui niche de brest l'union européenne
va prendre des sanctions individuelles
contre les responsables de la junte
malienne qui entravent le processus de
transition et je rappelle que l'union
européenne a d'ores et déjà pris ses
responsabilités en adoptant des
sanctions mois de décembre contre le
groupe wagner ses cadres dirigeants et
ses entités enfin monsieur le sénateur
comme vous le relevez la france n'est
pas seule au sahel une dizaine de nos
partenaires européens se sont notamment
engagées dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
dans le cadre de la force takouba et
nous avons clairement indiqué aux côtes
et nos partenaires européens
et d'ailleurs nos partenaires
internationaux que nous souhaitons
poursuivre l'action de lutte contre le
terrorisme au mali mais pas n'importe
quel prix et pas n'importe quelles
conditions dans ce contexte des
consultations vont avoir lieu dans les
prochains jours avec nos partenaires
africains avec nos partenaires européens
avec nos partenaires internationaux
dans le cadre notamment de la coalition
internationale pour le sahel je remercie
monsieur cigolotti
merci monsieur le ministre la présence
française au mali se complique de jour
en jour nous ne sommes pas parvenus à
nous opposer à l'arrivée des mercenaires
russes il ya désormais urgence à prendre
des décisions fermes contre la junte qui
refuse de céder le pouvoir comme elle
s'y était engagée dans le cadre d'une
transition démocratique
merci
d'accord le cas notre collègue pierre
chareau pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur
madame la ministre au delà du saccage de
paris dû au manque de coordination des
chantiers des travaux et de la voirie
défoncer la situation parisienne en
matière de circulation et de
stationnement n'est plus acceptable on
vous le redit finir les compétences en
matière de circulation et de
stationnement entre la mairie et le
préfet de police la loi de 2007 17
relative au statut de paris a en réalité
introduit de la complexité dans un
dispositif qui est devenu complètement
illisible avant la loi de 2010 7 qui
aura bientôt cinq ans la rédaction les
articles avaient le mérite de me prévoir
qu'un seul régime qu'il s'agisse de
motifs d'ordre public ou liés à la
sécurité des personnes et des biens
c'est le préfet de police qui était
compétent un tiers les circulation et de
stationnement sur les voies parisienne
cette nouvelle répartition des
compétences entre la mer et le préfet
n'a pas réglé les difficultés à paris
bien le contraire que constate-t-on en
dépit d'une baisse de trafic automobile
les bouchons ont considérablement
augmenté paris serait devenu en 2019 une
des villes au monde qui connaît le plus
d'embouteillages dès 2017 lui rêvait
police avait pourtant prévenu des
difficultés d'intervention des véhicules
de secours mais aussi de police soient
concernés notamment le projet
d'interdiction de toute circulation
automobile rue de rivoli concernant le
périphérique parisien qui draine chaque
jour plus de 250 mille voitures il a
fallu l'intervention du préfet à nouveau
pour éviter que celui-ci passe
immédiatement à 50 km/heure à deux ans
et demi des jeux olympiques des mesures
législatives réglementaires doivent être
prises pour éviter que les j ne se
transforme dans un énorme bouchon
parisien il est urgent madame la
ministre que l'état reprenne la main ou
plutôt sur ces questions de circulation
et du stationnement à paris afin de
faire en sorte que madame hidalgo arrête
d'emmerder les franciliens et les
parisiens
on vous répondre la parole et à families
de l'existant la citoyenneté madame
tshikapa
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices à messieurs les sénateurs à
monsieur le sénateur pierre charon vous
avez tout à fait raison de pointer cette
problématique que vous avez parfaitement
bien décrite le stationnement comme la
circulation à paris sont des calamités
et tout le monde le sait y comme vous le
savez en matière de police de la
circulation et du stationnement et dans
la répartition des compétences entre le
maire de pargny et le préfet de police
elle est organisée par l'article l 25
12-14 du cgct le maire de paris détient
en effet depuis la loi du 27 février
2010 est relative au statut de paris la
compétence générale et le préfet de
police ne dispose plus que d'une
compétence d'exception aux abords des
sites dits sensibles de la capitale
comme vous j'ai observe les grandes
difficultés pour ne pas dire
l'incapacité de l'actuel maire de paris
anne hidalgo à réussir à se saisir de
cette compétence toutefois aux termes de
la convention de coordination de la
police municipale de la ville de paris
et des forces de sécurité de l'état du
19 octobre 2021 la police municipale
assure à titre principal la surveillance
du stationnement gênant gênant pardon
est abusif et en matière de
stationnement payant depuis la réforme
de la loi nome tam de 2015 la ville
détient une compétence exclusive c'est
enfin aussi la ville de paris et
gestionnaires de voirie pour l'ensemble
du territoire parisien avec le relatif
succès qu'on lui connaît je suis désolé
de le dire le gouvernement veut il
suffit de sortir pour le constater en
fait le gouvernement relève comme vous
les opérations successives d'aménagement
ont ralenti la circulation des
transports collectifs de surface
particulièrement des bus et soulève des
difficultés pour les services de secours
et d'intervention
donc nous sommes monsieur le sénateur
tout comme vous très préoccupé par la
situation qui est du ressort de la
mairie de paris en application du choix
du législateur de 2010 est de transférer
l'essentiel de la compétence de
circulation et de stationnement au maire
de paris c'est en tout cas l'état de la
loi c'est l'état les lois à l'heure
actuelle mais sur le sénateur je vous
remercie
monsieur charon
la parole était un collègue marie
arlette carlotti pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
la parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre jean yves le drian
a clairement affirmé que la présence de
la société wagner n'était pas compatible
avec la manière dont la france
conservait la lutte contre le terrorisme
au mali et nous sommes d'accord depuis
le 23 décembre des doutes c'est face
quant à l'implication de wagner sur le
théâtre malienne la presse rapporte les
premiers accrochages début 2022 des
miliciens de wagner près de bandiagara
les faits sont là les hommes de wagner
se déploie au mali ils ont été repérés à
ségou et le silence du gouvernement
malien ne pourra pas masquer longtemps
le cas le concert barbare de ces
mercenaires dans un conflit dont la
complexité ne serait être résolu par
visage d'une milice à la solde de
l'argent seul l'instabilité en sortira
gagnante et les conséquences seront
graves pour les populations maliennes
d'autant que la junte ne prévoit plus
d'élection est désormais dissin de
confisquer le pouvoir la ligne rouge a
été transgressés c'est un fait et
pourtant et pourtant il nous semble que
désormais votre objectif c'est que de
gagner du temps vous disiez tout à
l'heure nous faisons des consultations
c'est pourquoi nous demande donc
clairement de clarifier la position de
la france notre pays envisage-t-il de
rappeler ses troupes quel avenir pour la
force taku part comment la france
compte-t-elle mettre en oeuvre les
actions les sanctions décidées par
l'union européenne merci pour vos
réponses
cormier en charge du commerce extérieur
merci monsieur merci monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice carlotti
je les dis il y à quelques minutes la
présence de wagner est inacceptable la
non le report des élections de cinq ans
par la junte est inacceptable les pays
de la cedeao ont pris des décisions très
fortes que nous soutenons tous les pays
de l'union européenne
nous avons pris aussi un certain nombre
de décisions de sanction de sanctions
individuelles et des sanctions
collectives de sanctions contre wagner
également mais madame la sénatrice nous
ne pouvons pas prendre des décisions
unilatérales nous avons besoin de
consulter d'échanger avec nos
partenaires européens et nos partenaires
internationaux car nous ne sommes pas
seuls au sahel nous sommes présents au
sein de la force takouba avec les onze
états européens qui mettent à
disposition de cette force des forces
spéciales nous sommes présents également
aux côtés de la nation unies et de la
minus ma pour veiller à ce que les
accords de d'alger soit bien respecté
nous sommes présents aussi aux côtés de
nos partenaires sahélien dans le cadre
du g5 sahel bref nous devons prendre le
temps des échanges des discussions pour
prendre la meilleure décision possible
je l' ai rappelé tout à l'heure car il
est clair dans notre esprit que dans ce
contexte dans les prochains jours des
discussions devront avoir lieu pour
connaître précisément la position de la
france de l'union européenne dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent je
vous remercie
mais monsieur le ministre c'est jean
yves le drian lui même qui a défini la
ligne rouge et maintenant que nous y
sommes il donne l'impression de ne pas
avoir de solution et c'est cette
improvisation qui nous inquiète nous
sommes à un niveau de tension rarement
atteint qui a contraint le président de
la république à annuler son déplacement
à bamako et à gao sous raison de covin
on sait que c'est pas le cas que la
situation était explosive une situation
qui peut mettre en danger nos militaires
en opération vous vous escrimé à
convaincre la junte de renoncer avec
nerfs ne veulent rien entendre et les
invectives ne font pas une politique
alors vous n'avez pas voulu nous
répondre là maintenant je comprends
monsieur le ministre parce que je crois
qu il est vrai que sur ce point c'est le
président de la république qui doit
désormais dire aux français quelle
politique antiterroriste il doit mener
au mali
merci
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue christine
bonfanti-dossat pour le gros ps du
nickel
monsieur le président madame la ministre
il ya cinq ans dans un livre qu'il a
modestement appelé révolution
emmanuel macron dévoilé son petit
bréviaire de promesses électorales à
l'heure du bilan la révolution est bien
là mais pas celle espérée par les
français partout dans notre pays en
ville comme à la campagne
ce ne sont pas des émeutes comme aurait
pu s'en émouvoir luis thèse mais bel et
bien des révolution orchestrée par tous
par des voyous
depuis cinq ans aucun territoire on est
épargné c'est une élue du lot-et-garonne
qui vous le dit chaque jour c'est un
torrent de faits divers de délit de
crime qui viennent nourrir l'actualité
oui la grande leçon de ce quinquennat
c'est bien la faillite des manuels macro
sur le plan régaliennes fort avec les
faibles faible avec les forts le
président de la république a totalement
déserté le terrain de la sécurité alors
ma question est simple
que regrettez vous de ne pas avoir fait
pendant ce mandat en matière de sécurité
êtes vous vraiment fier de cette société
fracturée abîmé que vous allez laisser
aux français
pour vous répondre la parole local
charge de la citoyenneté
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice je suis très étonné
par votre question dans la mesure où il
ya à peine une semaine de cela on nous
reprochait au contraire le fait que le
président de la république prenne à bras
le corps la question la sécurité et
qu'ils soient en déplacement à nice avec
le ministre de l'intérieur et moi-même
au prêt à l'invitation d'ailleurs du
maire de nice christian estrosi estrosi
pardon que je salue pour son engagement
en matière de sécurité et à cette
occasion d'ailleurs le président de la
république a fait un certain nombre
d'annoncés il a commencé par dresser un
bilan
fondis lancé le recrutement de dix mille
policiers et gendarmes sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat c'est même poste que la
droite avait supprimé lorsqu'elle était
au pouvoir lorsque valérie pécresse
était ministre du budget et qu'elle
avait fait le choix de sabrer le budget
de la sécurité nous sommes en train de
faire en sorte de compenser cela le
président la république donc a fait le
bilan des actions menées par le
gouvernement notamment en matière de
recrutement le recrutement je l'évoqué
on peut évoquer également le plan
poignées de porte les nouveaux véhicules
pour donner plus de moyens aux policiers
et aux gendarmes à nos policiers et nos
gendarmes et d'ailleurs j'observe que
vous avez voté l'augmentation
considérable du budget de la sécurité et
vous nous avez donné quitus du fait que
c'était une véritable avancée enfin le
président la république a partagé les
premières grandes orientations de la
langue ni titres apportés par le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
auprès du premier ministre jean castex
cette grande loi qui permettra encore de
consolider les avancées du pays en
matière de sécurité
les propositions des parlementaires
seront évidemment les bienvenus pour la
compléter je vous remercie
donc tout va très bien madame la
marquise et pourtant la réalité c'est
une agression tout les 44 secondes 38 %
d'augmentation des agressions sexuelles
depuis 2010 est trois fois plus
d'agressions et de menaces contre les
élus depuis 2000
19,85 agressions par jour contre les
forces de l'ordre un taux d'homicides
parmi les plus élevés d'europe la liste
est longue alors madame la ministre
l'ivresse du pouvoir ne donne pas tous
les droits au président mais lui-même
pas au contraire des devoirs le premier
devoir est de protéger les français
[Musique]
la parole n'est pas le colonel catherine
morin desailly pour le rôle de l'union
sans plus
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
santé des solidarités que mon groupe
interrogeait déjà en juillet 2020 sur le
projet de plateforme des données de
santé des français le reste at arabe
censée regrouper à terme toutes nos
données jusqu'à celle des programmes du
séquençage de notre adn je
l'interrogeais sur l'attribution de sa
gestion à la multinationale américaine
microsoft soit imposée par son collègue
cédric haut sans appel d'un spécifique
aux pros texte incroyable qui
n'existerait aucune entreprise française
ou européenne capable d'alerter sur les
risques pour nos libertés publiques d'un
tel choix
la crise sanitaire ayant en plus mines
loupe sur ce sujet hypersensible des
données de santé
récemment nous apprenions le retrait en
rase campagne de ce projet encore en
gestation puisqu'il n'y aura pas de
demande d'habilitation auprès de la cnil
peut-on alors espérer la remise à plat
complète de ce projet ou faites-vous le
dos rond le temps de la campagne
électorale une pause pour arranger
ensuite un appel d'offres qui aurait
toujours un microsoft vient le
consortium bleus constitue avec orange
et capgemini à l'invitation de cédric oh
quel est le bilan de cette opération
surtout de son cours parle de 80
millions d'euros quand même vu ce coup
d'arrêt on peut comprendre les questions
des français les français ce sont leurs
données personnelles ce sont aussi leurs
impôts et leurs cotisations merci de
votre réponse pour vous répondre à part
konami en charge de donner mais madame
bourguignon merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice catherine morin
desailly la sécurisation des données et
de la confiance g16 sont essentiels au
développement de la plateforme des
données de santé la health data club
depuis sa création par la loi de juillet
2019 et vous l'avez rappelé les équipes
de plateformes sont pleinement mobilisés
pour accompagner les projets de
recherche notamment sur sa plateforme
technologique en accord avec le
ministère
le lte data web a retiré provisoirement
sa demande d'autorisation pour héberger
la base principale du système national
des données de santé cette décision est
prise dans un contexte où la cnil a
commencé à instruire l'arrêté
définissant la composition de ses bases
de données sensibles par essence cette
instruction une fois finalisé
consolidera l'ensemble du dispositif de
mise à disposition des données comme
prévu par le décret de juin 2021 nous
souhaitons assurer notre souveraineté
sur les données de santé des français
vous le conviendrait et nous
poursuivrons ce déploiement à compter du
moment où ces conditions de confiance et
de sécurité seront réunies entre temps
nous mobilisons tous les leviers
disponibles pour avancer le ministère a
demandé à l'assurance maladie en lien
avec cette plateforme d'élaborer un plan
d'action pour accélérer la fourniture
des données liées au système national
concerné les premiers résultats ont déjà
abouti avec une centaine de projets pour
2021 témoignant à la fois de la très
forte demande et de l'utilisation
croissante des données notre objectif
sera précisée au cours du mois de
janvier est de doubler le volume de
données mise à disposition pour les
projets de recherche afin de concilier
les attentes des porteurs de projets le
lte data se met donc bien en place il
n'est pas à l'arrêt il porte ses
premiers fruits mais ces avancées se
porte dans un cadre légal sécurisé est
renforcée par les avis de la cnil avec
le soutien constant du gouvernement nous
ne faisons pas de paris sur les données
de santé des français nous voulons des
résultats tangibles pour notre recherche
dans un cadre sécurisé et de confiance
la mort avec lui
madame la ministre vous ne m'avez pas
répondu sur la question très importante
à questions financières du coût de cette
date sommes censés faire à terme des
économies nous venons d'apprendre que
l'assurance-maladie refusé de verser sa
quote-part de 11.5 millions d'euros pour
alimenter le budget 2022 parce qu'elles
se posent beaucoup de questions sur
cette mise à l'arrêt maintenant je veux
rappeler au gouvernement que si c'est la
souveraineté qui est son objectif que
les données de france et des français
sont un actif stratégique majeur donc
très convoité pour les gars femmes
auxquelles vous confier tout aux presque
sans état d'âme ce sont les affaires
avant tout à partir de là tout le monde
ici sera d'accord je pense nous exigeons
désormais la plus grande transparence et
rigueur dans tout projet d'utilisation
de nos données quel que soit le
ministère quel que soit l'organisme
concerné nous exigeons aussi le stockage
et le traitement de nos données sur le
sol européen par des entreprises mes
chers collègues européenne qui respecte
notre législation et protègent non
libertés fondamentales ce n'est pas
actuellement le cas du qatar hub et bien
sûr contre les jo une refondation
complète ne serez astarac ils devaient
se poursuivre mais aussi
la parole étant le prix collègue valérie
boyer on veut groupe l'est républicain
mais ce ministre
ma question porte sur les menaces de
mort du président autocrate de
l'azerbaïdjan imanaliev à l'encontre de
notre candidate valérie pécresse lors de
son déplacement en arménie en axa je
veux saluer sa démarche sincère et
courageuse cohérente avec ses
engagements valérie pécresse michel
barnier et bruno retailleau se sont
rendus à plusieurs reprises au chevet
des chrétiens d'orient des yézidie et
des kurdes en irak au kurdistan comme de
nombreux d'entre nous d'ailleurs c'est
le parlement avec gérard larcher avec
bruno retailleau avec l'ensemble des
groupes du sénat qui a été l'honneur de
la diplomatie française le 25 novembre
2020 en faisant voter une résolution en
nous rendant dès avril 2021 en arc
alors que la france préside le conseil
de l'union européenne votre silence est
d'autant plus condamnable et inquiétant
nous ne pouvons pas nous condamner d'une
réponse en catimini du chef de l'état
qui nous rappelle que la loi oblige dans
cette dictature et ne la condamne même
pas et ne soutient même pas ses élus
pourquoi ne pas exiger des excuses
solennelles de l'azerbaïdjan
pour vous répondre la parole est aux
ministres aux chats
des du commerce extérieur d'attractivité
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice valérie boyer ou matic vous
attirer mon attention sur les
déclarations du président aliev lors
d'une interview du 12 janvier qui a fait
suite d'ailleurs au déplacement de
madame pécresse haut karabagh jean yves
le drian là très clairement rappelé dans
l'hémicycle hier à l'assemblée nationale
ces propos sont inacceptables
c'est la position du gouvernement
français qui a d'ailleurs été rappelés à
l'ambassadeur d'azerbaïdjan en france
pour autant je vous dire que nous
n'avons pas attendu le déplacement
madame pécresse pour agir en solidarité
avec le peuple arménien et pour faire en
sorte que la crise dans cette région du
monde ça pèse la france en effet madame
la sénatrice est au rendez vous de la
solidarité avec le peuple arménien
depuis ce terrible conflit de l'automne
2020 et j'avais d'ailleurs eu l'occasion
d'en parler suite à une de vos questions
il n'y a pas si longtemps nous sommes à
raison du lien historique et culturel
qui nous lie avec le peuple arménien une
assistance humanitaire importante a été
apportée la demande du président de la
république d'ailleurs nous avons signé
il ya quelques semaines une feuille de
route bilatérale pour le développement
de notre coopération économique jean
baptiste lemoyne la faire au nom de la
france et la france est aussi au
rendez-vous de la responsabilité pour
trouver une solution durable à ce
conflit dans le cadre de notre mandat
vous le savez deux coprésidents du
groupe de minsk ces efforts se
poursuivent aujourd'hui en lien avec
l'union européenne dans le contexte de
la présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne je vous rappelle que
le président la république a réuni à
bruxelles le 15 décembre dernier le
premier ministre passe chinian et le
président aliyev pour justement
rechercher des solutions à ce conflit et
c'est cela madame la sénatrice sans
polémique sans essayer d'
instrumentaliser quoi que ce soit à
visée électorale qui est notre
responsabilité
bon malgré vos explications
l'ambassadeur azerbaïdjanais nie
toujours c'est menacent et nous narguent
en considérant que valérie pécresse n'a
pas respecté la loi serbe et janet sur
un territoire qui lui appartient même
pas en diffusant défectueuse et des
photos truquées mais qui a violé les
lois en bombardant civile église en
utilisant des andes est interdite en ne
rendant pas les prisonniers de guerre
qui qualifie nos alliés arménien de
chiens qui envoient des mercenaires
djihadistes qui menacent la paix en
attaquant un territoire souverain qui et
l'arménie valérie pécresse s'est rendue
en art ça car elle croit en la dignité
des peuples elle croit aux nations
souveraines qui doivent maîtriser leur
décision et protéger leur peuple et leur
civilisation valérie pécresse préfère la
sobriété de l'action la fidélité de ses
engagements à l'agitation de la
communication et des compromissions
comme de nombreux parlementaires qui
sont rendus en arc sarc comme jaurès au
parlement en 1895 valérie pécresse a
voulu témoigner en femme d'état et je le
cite devant tout ce sang versé de vente
et abomination et ces sauvageries devant
cette violation de la parole de la
france et du droit humain pas un cri
n'est sorti de vos bouches pas une
parole n'est sorti de vos consciences et
vous avez assisté muet à l'extermination
complète alors monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui en tant que membre du groupe
de mx nous ne pouvons plus nous réfugier
derrière cette neutralité être neutre
c'est choisir son camp et jamais nous
pouvons choisir celui de la classe
dictature et de l'abjection
merci la parole est à notre collègue
laurence arrivée pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et république
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président en france
chaque année cent mille jeunes quittent
le système scolaire sans diplôme ni
qualification
les jeunes sont et si les plus touchés
par le chômage et la précarité et en
france ils sont exclus des minima
sociaux au contraire des 23 pays
européens sur les vingt-sept
2022 a été proclamée année européenne de
la jeunesse c'est aussi le 35e
anniversaire d'erasmus or dans le
programme de la présidence française une
seule présidence une seule proposition
concrète
le service civique européen mais je suis
étonné et je vous demande si vous le
savez le service volontaire européen
existe depuis 20 ans déjà et transformé
en 2018 encore européen de solidarité
alors quel est le sens de cette annonce
demain à lagence français rami erasmus
seront présentés les propositions issues
des consultations jeunes dans le cadre
de la conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe visiblement ils aspirent à du
concret et à une application une
amplification des actions en faveur de
tous les jeunes quelle réponse leur
ferez vous
on vous répond la foire d'été en charge
limitation et au rire madame nathalie et
l'image de la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice sénatrice
pardon laurence harribey l'anjou
remercie de nous poser cette question
qui me permet de présenter devant le
sénat les orientations de notre
ministère pour la jeunesse effectivement
à l'occasion de la paix fut la
commission a publié le 14 octobre
dernier une proposition de décision du
parlement européen et du conseil de
l'union européenne vous l'avez dit sur
une année européenne de la jeunesse pour
2022 cette initiative est destinée à
mieux accompagner les jeunes dans la
sortie de la crise sanitaire et à les
aider à surmonter son impact négatif
cette décision fixe quatre objectifs que
je vais rappeler aujourd'hui et bien sûr
que nous aurons à coeur de mettre en
oeuvre tout d'abord rappelé que les
transitions verte et numérique offre une
nouvelle perspective d'avenir et des
possibilités de contrer l'impact négatif
encore une fois de la pandémie sur les
jeunes ensuite encouragé tous les jeunes
en particulier ceux issus des milieux
défavorisés à devenir des citoyens
actifs et engagés et des acteurs du
changement et je pense là bien sûr à
l'engagement civique promouvoir les
possibilités offertes par les politiques
publiques au niveau européen national
régional et local afin de soutenir leur
développement personnel social et
professionnel dans un monde vert
numérique et surtout inclusif enfin
intégrer la politique de jeunesse dans
tous les domaines pertinents de la
politique de l'union afin d'encourager
la prise en compte de leurs points de
vue dans l'élaboration des politiques
publiques à tous les niveaux il s'agit
de la clause d'impact jeunesse que nous
appliquons déjà madame la sénatrice à
l'occasion de cette présidence la france
sera aux côtés des institutions
européennes des états membres et de
l'ensemble des parties prenantes pour
piloter à l'échelle européenne durant
ces six mois quelques sujets d'intérêt
pour la jeunesse européenne et bien sûr
à les mettre à l'ordre du jour du
conseil je pense évidemment au soutien à
la mobilité des jeunes dans un autre
pays de l'union européenne afin qu'elle
soit plus inclusive et ce en lien avec
les annonces du président de la
république française sur le service
civique européen vous l'avez dit et je
le répète nous fêtons d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui les 35 ans d'erasmus au
cours je mens également au mentorat
sujet sur lequel le gouvernement
travaille et qui pourrait être portée à
l'échelle européenne je vous remercie
je vous pose la question des priorités
de la présidence française vous me
répondez par les priorités de la
commission européenne c'est étrange
je vous parlais de 10 service volontaire
européen vous me répondez par une
annonce du gouvernement français sur le
service civique qui existent et qui en
fait un effet d'annoncé un gadget une
politique de jeunesse ne se mène pas à
coups d'annoncés ou de gadgets ça
suppose une politique de fond dans la
durabilité et ça suppose surtout
d'accompagner les acteurs associatifs et
de leur permettre d'être encore plus
performants dont l'implication des
programmes européens ce qu'ils essayent
de faire depuis 30 ans
c'est un enjeu de taille mais c'est un
jeu un enjeu qui vaut le coup ce matin
le président disait qu'il fallait faire
de l'europe une puissance démocratique
culturel et d'éducation on ne peut pas
faire l'impasse de la jeunesse pour
aboutir à ce résultat
merci
la parole est à notre collègue martin
berthet pour le groupe public
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre il ya un an le 27 janvier 2021
je vous interpeller en séance comme
aujourd'hui sur l'inquiétude des
communes de stations de nos massifs
montagneux quant à leurs difficultés
budgétaires et de trésorerie des
réponses ont été apportées par les lois
de finances de 2021 et de finances
rectificative de juillet 2000 20 et 21
mai rien ne leur a été versée ou si peu
et sans commune mesure par rapport aux
pertes subies et aux dépenses nouvelles
de gestion de la crise sanitaire si les
compensations ont été apportées aux
professionnels de la montagne ce dont
chacun se félicite les communes n'ont
pas été compensés des pertes en recettes
de taxe professionnelle et touristique
taxe de séjour taxe sur les remontées
mécaniques et d'autre or la baisse
catastrophique d'activité sur l'hiver
20-21 a provoqué pour ces collectivités
des pertes de recettes en moyenne de
-70% pouvant atteindre jusqu'à -90% d
exemple madame la ministre que vous
connaissez puisque vous avez vérifié
auprès des trésoreries la véracité des
plaintes des maires de montagne pour la
seule année 2000 21 une perte de 500
mille euros pour saint lary soulan dans
les pyrénées de plus de 300000 euros
pour isola dans les alpes-maritimes d'un
million pour valoir de 5 pour
bourg-saint-maurice en savoie la commune
des belleville sur 6 millions d'euros de
pertes aperçu un acompte de 100 mille
euros en novembre 2021 ce montant est
fondé sur 30% de la somme perçue en 2020
ce qui représente vous le voyez une
somme dérisoire au regard des pertes
réelles admettez que cette situation
n'est pas tenable
ces communes se demande comment
équilibrer leur budget de fonctionnement
sur dimensionné pour la population de
ristic et ne seront plus en capacité
d'investir affectant alors gravement
l'économie pour autant leur contribution
démesurée au pic est toujours exigé
alors madame la ministre je vous le
demande comment vont elles faire
pour vous répondre attendant les cas la
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales d'amour au
président madame la sénatrice
martin pertes et
bien entendu les finances des communes
montagnardes ont été lourdement mis à
contribution effectivement dès 2020 et
de manière très marquée en 2021 avec la
fermeture des remontées mécaniques
l'hiver dernier par conséquent plusieurs
mesures de compensation ont été prises
je parle bien entendu d'abord du filet
de sécurité sur les recettes fiscales
qui vont en 2020 et en 2021 au sein
duquel la spécificité des territoires de
montagne est reconnue avec une
comptabilité ou une comptabilisation
plus exactement plus favorable de la
taxe de séjour dans les calculs pour
l'exercice 2009 1 ceci a donné lieu à
une compensation de enfin des
compensations de 2 millions 8 pour votre
département j'ai regardé votre
département et pour l'exercice de vin
2021 effectivement d acompte de 30 % de
la dotation 2020 ont été versés aux
communes vous avez raison je sais que
des critiques et vous venez d'en faire
une ont été exprimés et je voudrais vous
dire clairement que les élus ont leur
confirmant qu en attendant les calculs
des dotations finales qui doivent se
faire les communes peuvent solliciter
auprès des préfets et des décès fip un
ajustement du montant des douzièmes de
fiscalité il fixé à partir de janvier
avec olivier dussopt tu nous avons passé
des consignes au préfet de la savoie en
ce sens et certains dossiers complexes
comme celui de belleville sont en voie
de règlement le premier ministre l'a
écrit à l'association nationale dès
maires des stations de montagne afin
qu'il relaie ce message auprès des élus
deuxièmement je rappelle que nous avons
analysé de nombreux services et
équipements publics gérés en régie et ça
c'est très important cela a donné lieu
en savoie par exemple à 4,5 millions en
2020 et cela sera fait bien sûr en 2021
troisièmement je rappelle aussi que
l'état à indemniser les pertes
d'activités des exploitations de
remontées mécaniques
même si celles ci sont gérés en régie
publique dans les mêmes conditions que
le nous l'avons fait pour le privé voici
en quelques mots madame la sénatrice des
éléments factuels qui montre bien que
l'on sort côté des communes de montag
stations de montagne madame verte et
quelques secondes oui madame la ministre
je vous remercie mais depuis un an sur
les versements qu'ils attendent nos
maire n'entendent que des promesses ils
en ont assez de vos promesses à présent
ils veulent du concret mais si
on part en laisse à notre collègue
devant les grilles pour l'euro de
l'union centriste
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre en charge de l'enfance
joseph trois ans est atteint d'une
leucémie
plus de cent jours d'hospitalisation
793 chimiothérapie une chance sur un
million de guérir courageux face à la
maladie tout comme sa famille ce petit
garçon est depuis quelques jours au
coeur de l'actualité
alors que le processus médical toucher à
sa fin et qu'on espérait une issue
heureuse le petit joseph a fait une
rechute les parents désespérés lance un
appel aux donneurs de moelle osseuse via
les réseaux sociaux sans ce dont joseph
ne survivra pas
cet appel a largement été repris par les
médias monsieur le ministre à votre tour
allez vous relayer cet appel avec les
moyens de la puissance publique au delà
du drame vécu par joseph et sa famille
cette question pose le problème de la
rareté des donneurs volontaires inscrits
au registre international dédié la
pénurie est endémique
l' agence de biomédecine recherche en
permanence de nouveaux donneurs certains
freins administratifs sont
incompréhensibles alors que l'on peut
donner sa moelle osseuse jusqu'à 60 ans
on ne peut s'y inscrire qu'entre 18 et
35 ans pourquoi pas plus tard alors que
c'est le cas dans d'autres pays
mais le principal obstacle au
développement du fichier des donneurs et
le manque d'information les gens
ignorent l'étendue des besoins et de
nombreuses idées reçues perdure à titre
d'exemple pourquoi être inscrit dans le
fichier des donneurs pour être inscrit
dans le fichier des donneurs il suffit
simplement de procéder à un prélèvement
salivaire ou sanguin monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement va-t-il prendre
les mesures nécessaires pour enfin
faciliter le don de moelle osseuse et
lancer une campagne d'information pour
développer le fichier des donneurs
merci on nous répond maintenant le duo
secteur déclare charge de l'enfance et
des familles monsieur vrille attaquer si
monsieur le président la met sénatrice
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur jean un grès je
suis évidemment sensibles comme chacun
d'entre vous ici situation individuelle
dramatique et la situation du petit
joseph que vous avez vous avez rappelé
et vous me donnez d'ores et déjà
l'occasion et vous l'avez fait avant moi
de mettre la lumière sur sa situation
donner quelques éléments sur ce sujet
comparaître toujours difficile de
répondre à des questions empreinte
d'émotion parce qu'elle renvoie des
situations vécues par un enfant et par
parent sa famille
vous dire que nous réalisons aujourd'hui
2000 greffe de moelle par an que vous
l'avez dit c'est une thérapeutique il
repose sa compatibilité entre un donneur
et un receveur celle ci elle est
automatique entre des jumeaux elle est
de un sur quatre au sein d'une fratrie
elle est de un sur un million
entre deux individus pris au hasard
c'est la raison pour laquelle l agence
de la biomédecine gère le registre
france greffe de moelle mais qui est
connecté qui comporte trois cent vingt
mille d'honneur mais qui est connecté
avec ceux de 73 autres pays
néanmoins et qui permet donc de pouvoir
avoir accès à 40 millions de donneurs
potentiels
nous poursuivons pour autant par
ailleurs un objectif d'augmentation du
nombre de ses donneurs potentiels de
plus de 20 mille par an pour disposer de
la plus grande diversité de profils
possibles évidemment et nous cherchons
par ailleurs à faciliter les procédures
d'inscription sur le registre qui
aujourd'hui réalisées en ligne vous
l'avez évoqué c'est des objectifs qui
font partie du prochain plan ministériel
pour la greffe de cellules souches
hématopoïétiques
pour les années 2002 2026 qui feront
l'objet qui fera l'objet d' annonces
dans les semaines à venir sous l'égide
d'olivier vers ans et je souhaite
relayer renforcer la pelle vous me
appelé donc je le jeu le fait de
l'inscription de nouveaux donneurs en
attirant l'attention sur le dé
recrutement prioritaire
prioritaire est explicite et peut-être
les raisons pour lesquelles ces moments
laissez-le la possibilité monsieur le
président effectivement deux jeunes de
18 à 35 ans car leurs greffons sont plus
riche en cellules souches et permettent
donc une prise de greffe plus rapide
pour les patients avec une efficacité
non pas garanti mais en tout cas plus
grande ni enfin des hommes car les
cellules souches de la moelle osseuse
sont dépourvus d anticorps que
développent les femmes durant leur
grossesse
voilà toutes les informations utiles à
la compréhension de ce geste à
l'inscription comme donneurs sont toutes
accessibles sur le site dont je permets
de faire la promotion don de moelle
osseuse point fr don de moelle osseuse
ce point fr je me joins à vous pour
amplifier la peine effectivement
bénéfice de ce petit joseph et des
joseph avenir
plus sûr et grêle
monsieur le ministre je m'étais permis
de vous poser la question notamment sur
le fait d'étendre l'âge pour être
enregistrée légalement ses 18 35 ans
dans notre pays mais dans d'autres pays
comme en belgique ou en suisse on peut
aller minimum jusqu'à 40 ans jusqu'à 55
ans pour être enregistrés des catégories
d'âge comme la mienne n'ont jamais été
comment dire sensibilisés que ce soit au
moment de l'école mais aussi dans
l'enseignement supérieur lors du passage
à l'université ce qui serait bien si je
puis me permettre c'est aussi avec vos
collègues ministres de sensibiliser à
l'école et à l'université
merci
la parole
draghi pour les signatures mais figurant
sur la liste aucun euro vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
malgré son absence ma question sera
comme imposer un monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur la liberté d'expression est
un principe fondamental de notre
république
voilà ce que déclare et gérald darmanin
en novembre 2020 ministre de l'intérieur
vous êtes le garant de nos libertés qui
sont protégés par les forces de l'ordre
que vous dirigez vous monsieur d'un
marin vous n'étiez pas à ibiza vous avez
donc dû voir passer l'information
plusieurs interventions de
parlementaires contre le passé vaccinale
ont été censurés par youtube ou facebook
s'il n'y a plus de délit de blasphème en
france les gallois ont créé le blasphème
sanitaires bastien lachaud député rfi
mon collègue l'assemblée nationale
nicolas maisonnée et moi-même en avons
été victimes alors qu'ils s'en prennent
au président des états unis il y a deux
ans c'était déjà limite mais sans
prendre en bois en moi monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ou
conviendrait quand même que là ça va
trop loin à l'aube d'une campagne
présidentielle cruciales pour l'avenir
du pays les français ont besoin d'être
rassurés que leur principale source
d'information les réseaux sociaux
demeurera libre aux personnes ne sont
pas sacrées mais notre liberté
d'expression elle l'est et en
particulier dans les hémicycles du
parlement le coeur même de notre
démocratie
pendant des mois on a essayé de nous
faire peur avec une prétendue ingérence
russe qui allait renverser les urnes du
monde libre la réalité c'est que la
seule ingérence étrangère de plus en
plus totalitaire ne vient pas du kremlin
mais dans la silicon valley de quelques
milliardaires en jean baskets reçus
comme des chefs d'état l'elysée qui
veulent influer sur les élections grâce
à leur entreprise planétaire vous n'avez
donné aucune garantie depuis cinq ans à
ce sujet alors même que vous avez fait
passer une loi contre les fausses
informations à ce titre monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur vous en avez
vous-même propager une ce dimanche vous
avez fait croire que des manifestants
contre le passage final défilé le bras
tendu alors qu'ils étaient en train de
réaliser un clapping c'est-à-dire de
taper dans leurs mains comme ça existe
dans tous les stades de france alors
monsieur le ministre ma question est
double après cet épisode navrant qui
démontre que vous avez décidez vous
aussi d'emmerder les non-vaccinés
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout du fake que
comptez vous faire pour protéger la
liberté d'expression et ne craignez pas
monsieur le ministre d'être condamné à
votre tour pour propagation de fausses
informations pour vous répondre la
parole est à la ministre délégué en
charge de la citoyenneté
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices mais sur les sénateurs à
monsieur sénateurs je ne suis pas gérald
harlin or je suis ministre délégué
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur chargé
de la citoyenneté j'ai été désigné par
le premier ministre pour vous répondre
c'est donc ce que je vais faire d'abord
peut-être vous dire que la liberté
d'expression sur les réseaux sociaux
comme la liberté d'expression dans la
vie elle n'est pas infinie elle est
encadrée par la loi par exemple diffusé
des fausses informations inciter des
gens à mettre leur vie en danger ça ne
relève pas de la liberté d'expression
insulter ou menacé de mort des élus sur
les réseaux sociaux ça ne relève pas de
la liberté d'expression menacée de mort
des journalistes lancé des raids de
cyber harcèlement comme récemment contre
la petite camille de l'association un
sourire pour camille sur les réseaux
sociaux ça ne relève pas de la liberté
d'expression monsieur le sénateur donc
oui nous sommes attachés à la liberté
d'expression à la liberté d'expression
des parlementaires et dans cet hémicycle
bien évidemment elle est pleine et
entière et c'est pourquoi nous pouvons
avoir cet échange en dehors également
que la liberté d'expression elle n'est
pas sans limite c'est pourquoi nous
avons pris des lois pour faire en sorte
par exemple qu'on ne puisse pas au nom
de la liberté d'expression sur des
réseaux sociaux diffuser l'adresse
personnelle d'un professeur ou d'un
policier sur les réseaux sociaux en
menaçant leur vie comme ça a été le cas
pour saluer lé pa ti par exemple et
c'est pour ça que nous avons renforcé la
loi dans le projet loi pour conforter
les principes de la république et je
vous remercie pour vos votes et pour
vous à jouer à cette occasion c'est pour
cela que le ds a au niveau européen sera
discuté et je l'espère adopté dans la
semaine dans la continuité des annonces
du président de la république et c'est
pourquoi également avec le premier
ministre castex et le gars de détonique
dupond-moretti nous étions cette semaine
chez pharos et au parquet national de
lutte contre la haine en ligne qui ont
été créées par les dispositions de ce
gouvernement pour faire en sorte de
mieux protéger les citoyens sur les
réseaux sociaux car ils n'ont pas à être
menacés que ce soit sur les réseaux
sociaux ou dans la vie je veux merci
merci
merci monsieur le premier ministre si
mesdames et messieurs les mines et les
prochaines questions d'actualité au
gouvernement rend lieu le mercredi 26
janvier à 15 heures se veut suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 16h40 pour
l'examen de la deuxième lecture la
proposition de loi visant à renforcer le
droit à l'avortement l'assurance est
suspendu
[Musique]
voilà vous avez pu suivre en direct et
en intégralité la séance de questions au
gouvernement tout de suite place au
débrief et on va tout de suite rejoindre
alexandre poussard car alexandre vous
êtes salle des conférences avec le
président du groupe écologiste au sénat
le sénateur un guillaume gontard
bonjour
ainsi la cible
le problème
aussi problème de sont décidément comme
c'est réglé voilà
le contraire je disais que cet
après-midi les beaucoup de questions sur
edf et le gouvernement qui demande au
groupe de baisser les prix de
l'électricité